The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I guess we'll get started.
So last time we were talking
about the auditory midbrain,
where the big structure is
the inferior colliculus.
And we talked about
its inputs coming
from the superior
olivary nuclei,
like the lateral
superior olive, which
has neuron sensitive to
enter oral level differences,
and another input
being the MSO, where
the neurons insensitive
to binaural stimuli
with interaural
time differences.
And those inputs converge
on the inferior colliculus.
And in today's lecture,
we have a little slide
of the inferior colliculus.
And the big part of the inferior
colliculus, diagrammed here
is this central
nucleus, the ICC.
And that structure
has been well studied,
part because it's the big part.
It's easy to record from,
it's deep in the brain.
It has a strong
tonotopic organization.
We talked last time about
neurons there having
time intensity trading because
they get in some cases, input
from both LSO and MSO.
We talked about coding for
stimulating head precedence
like effects in the
inferior colliculus,
and we talked a little bit about
sound localization in there
in the mammal, at
least for the parts
of the inferior colliculus
that had been studied,
there being no really good or
obvious map of sound location
to place in the colliculus,
and we also talked about some
of the other edge
regions of the colliculus
like the external nucleus
of the colliculus that
has been explored very
nicely in the bar now.
And we talked about
its projections
up to the optic tectum,
or the tectum in the bar
now, which is the analog
of the superior colliculus
in the mammal.
And there's this
beautiful mapping
of auditory space
in the barn owl
at that position in the brain.
Now, such mappings are
not found in general
in the auditory
system of mammals,
with the one exception
being in the deep layers
of the superior colliculus.
There are neurons that are
responsive to auditory,
as well as visual stimuli.
Of course, we think of
the superior colliculus
as being a visual nucleus.
And in those deeper
layers, there
is a mapping of
auditory space that's
in line with the mapping
for visual space there.
So it's as if a mapping of space
can be created in the mammal,
but it just doesn't
appear, at least
in the main nuclei of
the auditory pathway.
The superior colliculus is
really not an auditory nucleus.
OK.
So any questions from last time?
So today, we're going to
be talking about mainly
the auditory cortex
and how it has
a number of fields
in the cortex.
Usually we talk about
fields rather than nuclei,
and these fields
are tonotopically
organized-- at least,
several of them are.
And some of them
aren't, but we'll
be emphasizing the
tonotopic ones.
There are some very
interesting experiments
where investigators have
explored how changes in hearing
can affect the tonotopic
mappings in these fields
so that they can be plastic.
They can be molded or shaped
depending on experience.
So we'll talk about
that plasticity.
Because there are many
fields, the obvious question
is, well, what does one field
do in your sense of hearing,
and what does another field do.
And we're generally not able
to answer those questions.
I like to think that there
are Nobel Prizes waiting
to be earned in this area as
that function is worked out
for each of the fields.
But it's clear that there's a
big role of one field, which
we call A1, in
sound localization.
And we'll review that
line of investigation.
That if A1 is lost, an
experimental animal's ability
to localize sounds
is completely gone.
OK?
So we'll talk about
the evidence, how
we test animals for
sound localization.
Then we'll talk about where
A1 is in the human auditory
cortex.
And we'll talk finally about
some very interesting imaging
studies that have shown that
there is a center that lights
up in imaging studies
when you present
sounds with salient pitch.
That is, very strong
sensations of pitch,
and it's an area near A1,
but a little bit beyond it.
So we'll talk about
those imaging studies.
And that relates to
the paper that we
have for assigned reading
for today's lecture.
So that's the roadmap for today.
So the first slide is a
very complicated slide
that as I said, has the
inferior colliculus on it.
And in the second row, has
the auditory thalamus on it.
So the auditory thalamus
is the medial geniculate.
And I'm not going
to say very much
about the medial geniculate.
Probably Peter Schiller
talked a lot more
about the lateral geniculate in
the visual part of the course.
I want to just say that
there is a large part
of the medial geniculate called
the ventral division, indicated
here.
There's a couple
little symbols that
say v. That stands
for ventral division.
And there is a large part
of the medial geniculate
that is tonotopically organized.
And so it receives
a lot of input
from the central nucleus of the
colliculus, which is tonotopic.
It is tonotopic.
And it, in turn, projects
2 auditory cortical fields
that are listed up
there, which we'll
go over in detail
in just a minute.
And all of those
listed cortical fields,
with the exception of the
one that says t, all of those
are tonotopically organized.
So to some people
than, there is a part
of this auditory pathway
at these higher levels
that's called the
tonotopic system.
And that has a
bulk of the nuclei.
There are some other systems.
And at least in
this author's idea,
they're labeled as diffuse
and multisensory systems.
We're not going to
talk much about them.
But they start out in other
parts of the colliculus,
like the dorsal part
of the colliculus,
and the external nucleus
of the colliculus.
And they pass through other
divisions of the thalamus.
And they either go to other
auditory cortical fields,
like A2 here, or they
project diffusely
to a whole bunch of
places in auditory cortex.
So we're not going to emphasize
them very much at all.
Just stick with the
tonotopic system for now.
So in the auditory
cortex, there's
been a lot of research done
on the cortex of the cat.
Cat has been a standard
model for auditory cortex
work since the beginning,
since the '60s.
And so the fields are very
well known in the cat.
And they're indicated in
the colored shading here.
And this is showing
you the cat's brain
from looking at its left side.
So you see that the colored
areas, the auditory areas,
are in the part of
the brain called
the temporal cortex,
the side of the cortex.
So way up here would be the
frontal part of the cortex,
the frontal lobes here.
Way back here, you're familiar
with the occipital cortex,
which would be the visual areas.
And these areas are on the side,
our so-called temporal cortex.
Those are the auditory areas.
And the cat is a nice
model for cortex.
Because much of the big
auditory cortical field,
A1 here, is on the surface.
It's on a big gyrus
that's accessible.
You can get to it, you
can record from it.
You can make lesions in it.
A little bit of A1 goes
down into a sulcus.
And those sulci are
labeled by the lines.
This one is labeled ps, the
posterior ectosylvian sulcus.
And this is the cortex with
the cortex map pulled apart.
So you can see the parts
of the cortex that's
down in the sulcus.
And those are the
dark pink here.
And in the front part, rostral
part of the auditory cortex,
there's another anterior
ectosylvian sulcus.
And that's shown by
the dark pink here.
So much of A1 is on the
surface, but a little bit of it
dives down into a sulcus.
Now, when you go with
microelectrodes and record
from the auditory cortex,
you take off the skull,
you take off the dura,
and you see the cortex.
And you can take
your microelectrode
and go right into the cortex.
And of course, the
cortex has layers.
So you'd be going, starting
in layer 1, and going down.
How many layers are
there in cortex?
There's 6, right?
OK.
And you find that if you go
down through all those layers
and make recordings in
the different layers,
all of the neurons in
one cortical penetration
with your electrode
have the same CF.
So of course, we want to measure
the characteristic frequency
from the tuning curve, just
like we do in other places.
And if you do that,
in these recordings
you find that they
all have the same CF.
And that's like going down
through a cortical column.
So columnar organization is
very important in cortex.
And if we draw it from the
side, this would be the surface.
And you'd have these 6
layers usually labeled
by Roman numerals.
And your electrode would be
coming down here and sampling
from the various layers,
single neurons at a time.
Of course, you'd have to
maybe record from layer 1
first, then layer 2, and
then so on, and so forth.
And as long as you stay
within a column of cortex,
the neurons have the same
characteristic frequency.
So looking at it from
the surface here then,
one column would be like a dot.
You'd be looking
down at the very top
of the column from the capital
down to the base of the column,
if it were an
architectural column.
When you do that, you
can make a CF mapping
for these tonotopic fields.
And you find that if you're
way over here, rostral in A1,
you get very high CFs.
And so high CFs for a cat would
be like 40 kilohertz, maybe
even 50 kilohertz.
An octave beyond the upper
limit of human hearing.
But if you move your
electrode, more caudally,
the CFs get lower,
and lower, and lower
until you reach the
posterior edge of A1.
And this little
word, "low" means,
that's where the lowest
CFs in A1 would be found.
And the low CFs would be like
0.1 kilohertz, 100 Hertz.
If you went perpendicular to
that so-called tonotopic axis,
you can have recordings that go
one here, one there, one there,
one there.
If you're moving up
from ventral to dorsal,
then you find they
all have the same CFs.
So that's an iso CF.
Lamina, if you will.
And it starts right here.
This line right here
is an iso CF lamina.
This would be the highest CFs.
And then as you go
caudally the CFs
get lower, and lower, and lower.
Then, when you keep moving
your electrode, more and more
caudally, you find further CFs.
And then the
progression changes.
The CFs start to become
higher, and higher, and higher.
That's the signal that you've
entered another auditory
cortical field right behind A1.
And it gets its name
from being behind it,
behind an anatomical
terminology is posterior.
So this field is p,
or sometimes called
PAF, posterior auditory field.
And if you keep going,
more and more caudally.
In this case, the
thing takes a turn.
So you go, caudally and
ventrally, the CFs then
start to get higher, until
you approach the boundary of p
with the next auditory
cortical field, which is VP.
Ventral posterior
auditory field.
Then the CFs go
from high to low.
Same thing happens where A1
meets the anterior auditory
field, indicated by a here.
Those two fields share a high
frequency, high CF boundary.
And then, as you
go more rostral,
the CFs get lower,
and lower, and lower.
Sometimes this organization,
at the edges of the fields,
is called, mirror image
tonotopy in the auditory system.
And where else have
you guys seen this?
Did you go over this in the
vision part of the course
where you have the mapping
of the retina on V1
in the occipital cortex, right?
And it has a retina
topic mapping.
And that has some image where
the nasal part of the retina
is over here, and the temporal
part of the retina's over here.
And where V1 abuts V2, you also
have a retina topic mapping.
But it's a mirror
image reversal of V1.
So you should have
gone over that
in the visual part
of the course.
You find such mirror image flips
in the somatosensory cortex.
In the somatosensory
cortex, there's
a mapping of the body surface.
If you touch here
on the body surface,
a certain part of the
somatosensory cortex responds.
If you touch up here, a
different part responds.
And there's a mapping
of the body surface
onto the surface of the cortex.
And where S1 meets S2,
there's also a mapping.
But it's a mirror image.
OK.
So this is not a
surprise in terms
of general cortical
organization.
And it's also not a surprise
in the visual periphery.
You have the retina
topic mapping.
In the auditory periphery,
you have the CF mapping.
And you have this nice CF
mapping along the cortex.
OK.
And in the cat, you have
these four tonotopically
organized system fields.
And you have several
fields; A2, DPV, and T,
where the tonotopy is either
nonexistent, or much less
obvious.
And there are some
challenges here
to exploring responses
in these other areas.
For example, tuning curves in
A2 can sometimes look like this.
And it's very difficult
then, to assign a CF
to such a broad bowl
shaped tuning curve.
You could do it, if you
really were pressed.
But there's not much difference
between that frequency
and that frequency.
So this could be an
octave or more difference.
And so it's hard to
assign a CF to some
of the neurons in
these other fields.
That's not true in A1.
In the tonotopically
organize fields in general,
there's very precise,
sharp frequency tuning.
OK.
So the tuning curves,
there's a little table here.
They're usually sharp in these
tonotopically organized fields.
Yes, there's tonotopic
organization.
The latency is short.
The response is brisk
or robust compared
to response that might be
called poor or insecure.
That just simply means, every
time you turn on a sound,
and people remember,
typically tend
to measure histograms
in response
to hundreds of sound bursts
every time there's a response.
But here, there
might be a response
to the first tone
burst in a train.
And then the neuron might shut
down and not respond anymore.
So these diffuse areas
are hard to investigate.
Most of these cortex
recordings I'm talking about
have been done in
anesthetized animals.
And so there's
always a question of,
how much has anesthesia
changed the response patterns?
Of course, anesthesia
has a big effect
on these higher levels
of the nervous system.
So it's not always clear
how much of these properties
or change in these properties
has been due to anesthesia.
So back to the
somatosensory cortex.
Here's a mapping of the
And this is the
surface of the body map
onto the surface of
the cortex that I
was referring to earlier.
So if you stimulate
the surface of the body
over here, the tips
of the toes, you
get a response here in
the somatosensory cortex.
If you stimulate the
fingers, you get a response
here in the
somatosensory cortex.
You stimulate the facial region,
you get a response over here.
And this distorted
mapping or caricature
of the body's surface,
sometimes called a homunculus.
And it shows you
that a lot of cortex
is devoted to certain
important parts of your body,
like the face.
And less important parts,
like the trunk of your body,
receives much smaller
representation in the cortex.
In the auditory
cortex, if you draw
the mapping-- so
here's a mapping of A1.
In this case, it's from
the guinea pig cortex.
And in this case, the
mapping is plotted
with the CF on the
y-axis, and the distance
along the cortex on the x-axis.
And these are the data.
Each dot indicates
a recording site
from a single column
in the cortex.
And if you could
read these numbers,
they would indicate the CFs.
And these lines are
the ISO CF contours.
And this CF axis is plotted
along this distance here.
So this distance
is going like this,
and this distance is
going along like this.
And there's a very nice,
almost linear relationship.
And it shows you
something quite different
from the somatosensory
mapping, which
is that there aren't any
really important frequencies.
They all have about the same
representation in the cortex.
It's a pretty boring,
straight line, if you will.
It's not as interesting
as the homunculus
in the somatosensory cortex.
So this is true in
the general mammal.
Next time, when we talk about
the auditory cortex in the echo
locating bat, we'll have
quite a different finding.
There are some very
important frequencies
in certain types of bats that
relate to the echo locating
signal that they
emit, and the echo
that comes back to them so
that they can find targets,
even in the dark.
But most of general mammals
do not echolocate, of course.
And so their mapping
of the sensory cortex
is pretty linear and
boring, if you will.
So today's reading
comes from what
motivates the next
experiment that I'll show.
For a long time,
these mappings were
thought to be laid down at
birth and not changeable.
So they were just immutable.
But some very
interesting experiments
by Dexter Irvine and Don
Robertson in the 1980s
showed that was not true.
And they were not the
pioneers in showing
that cortex can change as
a result of experiment.
Rather, some people who
were working, especially
in the somatosensory
cortex, were the first.
And so I didn't have
a reading for today.
So right before I came over, I
pulled up the Wikipedia entry
on the Silver Spring monkeys.
So has anybody heard of
the Silver Spring monkeys?
So Silver Spring monkeys were
in the news in the 1980s.
They got their name
from the Institute
of Behavioral Research in Silver
Springs, Maryland-- Silver
Spring, Maryland.
And from 1981 to
1991, they became
what one writer called, the most
famous lab animals in history,
as a result of battle between
animal researchers, animal
advocates, politicians,
and courts.
So there was a researcher
whose name was Edward Taub.
And he was experimenting on the
somatosensory sensory cortex.
And he was taking
the monkeys, and he
was denervating
the sensory input
from certain parts
of their limbs.
So for example, he would cut the
nerves that carried information
from the middle
finger of the monkeys.
And he was studying to see
if the somatosensory cortex
remapped, and he was
finding small effects.
But in May, 1981, Alex Pacheco,
from the animal rights group
PETA, began working
undercover in his lab,
alerted the police to what PETA
viewed as unacceptable living
conditions for the monkeys.
And there was a long battle.
Initially, the researcher was
convicted of animal cruelty,
and these charges were
subsequently overturned.
But anyway, the monkeys
were held in limbo
for in some cases, many
years because his research
was put on hold.
During the subsequent
experiments
on the monkeys after the
court battles were all done,
it was discovered that
significant cortical remapping
had occurred.
This is evidence of
the brain's plasticity,
and it helped to overturn the
widely held view that the old
adult brain cannot reorganize
itself in response to its
environment.
So the analogous experiments
in the auditory system
have been done in small animals.
And maybe it's a result
of much decline and use
of primates in research.
There was hardly
any auditory work
done on primates these days.
This reorganization work
is done in the guinea pigs.
And the experiments
are done like this.
There's a peripheral lesion
made in the cochlear.
In the Guinea pig
cochlear, it's very easy
to make a little hole
in the middle layer,
and look down on the cochlear.
And the cochlear's
a bony structure.
The most accessible part is
the basal turn of the cochlear.
And you can go right
through the round window
and see the basilar
membrane, and the hair cells.
And you can make a
little tiny pinpoint
opening in the organ of
corti with a fine metal pick,
and create a
substantial hearing loss
in one little place
of the cochlear.
So here is indicated a
graph of the compound action
potential threshold.
This is a response from
the auditory nerve.
Action potential,
obviously, is an impulse
from single auditory
nerve fibers.
Compound means it's a
recording from many, many,
if not all of the
auditory nerve in response
to a tone burst of the
different frequencies.
And if you make a small
lesion at the basal turn,
remember the frequency
organization of the cochlear
is such that the basal turn
processes, high frequencies.
And so instead of the normal
curve in the lesion animal,
you have a big increase in
threshold, maybe 60, or 70,
or 80 dB in the lesion case.
And that lesion goes
from about 10 kilohertz
to about 20 kilohertz.
And in other parts
of the cochlear,
the hearing is normal.
So this is a peripheral
hearing loss.
And now, we're going to
then look in the cortex
and see if the tonotopy
of the auditory cortex
is the same or different.
And obviously, my
big build up here,
that there's plasticity
of tonotopy, is found.
This is the normal
mapping that we first saw.
This is the mapping in
the lesioned animal.
And in this case, it's a mapping
where each of these dots,
of course, is a recording site.
These are very high CFs.
You march along here, and
the CF gets a little lower.
But there's a big region
of about 20 kilohertz--
big, long distance in the
cortex-- when all you get
is CFs of 20 kilohertz.
Notice that that is right
at the edge of the lesion.
In the lesion, between
20 and 10 kilohertz,
you don't get any response.
Well, there's a huge
hearing loss there.
It's no surprise that there's no
response to those frequencies.
The auditory periphery is
not sending you any messages,
or sending you very few messages
about those frequencies.
Then you jump a little
bit in distance.
And the CF jumped from
20 down to 10 kilohertz.
And there's a long
region of cortex
at which the CFs are
all 10 kilohertz.
And notice that 10 kilohertz
is a very important frequency
in the audiogram of this
animal, and that it's
right at the edge, the low
frequency edge of the hearing
loss.
After that extensive
region then, you
pick up your normal
tonotopy of auditory cortex.
So this is clearly a
massive reorganization
compared to the normal
of this lesioned animal's
cortical mapping.
So couple comments about this.
If you do the mapping
right after the lesion,
this reorganization
is not found.
So it takes some time.
In the case of the
auditory system,
it takes more than three weeks
to see the reorganization.
What's the mechanism
for this reorganization?
Well, we have input coming
up to here from the thalamus,
where the inputs
from the 20 kilohertz
place of the thalamus,
did they come up here?
And did they grow into a
large part of the cortex
where they weren't
present before?
And did they do that growth
because that part of the cortex
had gone silent because
of the hearing loss?
So one mechanism
could be growth,
if you will, sideways
growth of axons.
Another mechanism
could be the inputs
from the thalamus
are coming up here.
And even in the normal
case, they don't just
go to one place, but they have
all sorts of side branches.
And these side branches in
the normal case are inhibited,
or they're not
strong to begin with.
Because there's a lot of
other stuff coming in here,
and the other stuff is
saying, you guys be quiet.
I'm the main input.
And maybe after
the hearing loss,
that other stuff is silenced.
And these previously weak
inputs become stronger.
So you could say then
that another mechanism
is strengthening of
preexisting inputs
that are weak before
the perturbation.
And I wrote mechanism, ?
because we don't know
what the mechanism is.
And it may be both.
They're not mutually exclusive.
And we're thinking here, cortex.
This is a lecture on the cortex.
But I should bring up, where is
the locus of this plasticity?
So in the auditory system, we
have a rich array of nuclei.
We have the cochlear nucleus,
we have the superior olivary
complex, we have the
inferior colliculus.
We've just learned a little
about the auditory thalamus.
Well, could one of
those lower level nuclei
have reorganized, and
then just passively spit
their reorganized
input up to the cortex?
And the answer is yes, and that
actually has been looked at.
So there's no reorganization
in the cochlear nucleus.
The part of the cochlear nucleus
that processes 20 kilohertz
is supposed to be normal.
In between 20 and 10 kilohertz,
you have a normal region.
But it's completely silent in
these types of hearing loss.
You have a small amount
of reorganization
in the inferior colliculus.
But it's not as big as
what we see in the cortex.
And maybe in the
medial geniculate body,
we have a larger reorganization,
but probably not quite as much
as you do in the
auditory cortex.
So there may be a little
bit of reorganization,
an IC, a little bit in MGB,
and then further reorganization
in auditory cortex.
So that has been looked at.
And the answer is at all
of these higher levels,
there's reorganization.
But there's maybe more as
you go higher in the pathway.
Now, who cares?
We usually don't have
hearing losses, right?
Well I should remind
you that we had
a big lecture on hearing loss.
Then let me show you one
of the slides from it.
So we had this slide under
the lecture on hearing loss.
Well, I've given
it a new title now
because I was thinking
about getting old this week.
And the type of hearing loss
that you have when you get old
is called presbycusis.
Presbycusis is the
age related loss
of hearing, especially
at high frequencies.
And almost all of us are going
to go through presbycusis.
This is a normal audiogram
or threshold of hearing curve
when you're young, and this
is one when you get older.
And invariably, we lose
our high frequency hearing.
The causes are not known.
But clearly it takes
place in the periphery,
which is very similar to the
lesion study we just went over.
It's a peripheral
hearing loss, what
happens to your central pathway.
It probably results in cortical
reorganization in the human.
And again, I can't spell.
There's a missing t here.
So we probably all-- and
we have plenty of time.
This hearing loss
doesn't happen in days.
It happens over the
course of our lifetime.
There's plenty of time
to reorganize the cortex.
Now, let me go back
a little bit here
and ask an interesting
question which
has some negative answers,
and some positive answers.
People have said, well, wow.
This animal-- you
have a lot of cortex.
Half a millimeter devoted
to CFs of 20 kilohertz.
And you have a lot of cortex
devoted to CF of 10 kilohertz.
Does this animal do something a
lot better at those frequencies
than this normal animal
which just has a little bitty
part of cortex devoted
to 20 kilohertz,
and a little bit
devoted to 10 kilohertz.
So it's not clear what the
answer is to that question yet.
And people have
speculated in the normal--
if you train a normal
person or a normal animal
to do a task at 10 kilohertz.
So they're listing to 10
kilohertz over and over again.
It's clearly a training
effect for many tasks.
You get better with training.
Does that mean in
the normal case
that we enlarge the 10
kilohertz part of our cortex?
Well, it's not known.
Does that means this
big area of 10 kilohertz
and 20 kilohertz in the
lesioned animals cortex
enable that animal to
do something better?
That's not clear.
There's evidence for both
answers to those questions.
Let's move on to some
other properties that
have been observed
in auditory cortex.
And we've been stuck in
this mode and this course
on frequency organization.
It's clearly a very
strong component
of central auditory nuclei.
And here are some tuning curves
from auditory cortex neurons.
You have the x-axis
being frequency,
and the y-axis being
sound pressure level,
response being inside
the tuning curve.
In this case, they've
embellished the tuning curve
a little bit by plotting
the biggest, best
response in real black shading.
And these are the
tuning curves we've
been talking about in
the course all along.
You might see goes
from the auditory nerve
from cochlear nucleus
and lower levels.
In the auditory
cortex, you see some
of those kinds of tuning curves.
But you also see from
different neurons,
other types of tuning curves.
And these are seen to a greater
extent in the auditory cortex,
although you do see some,
to a certain extent,
in the colliculus, and
in the thalamus.
So you see them in a numerically
greater extent in the cortex.
And here is a tuning curve
that sure has a best frequency.
But at that best frequency, if
you get it higher and higher
in level, the neuron
actually stops
responding at a pretty moderate,
and certainly at a high level.
And if you study its response
inside the black shading,
you can say, well, that
neuron has the best
frequency, or
characteristic frequency.
It also has a
characteristic level.
It likes it a lot when the
tone frequency is 10 kilohertz,
and the tone level is 40 dB.
That's its maximal response.
That's the one it
prefers, if you will.
Here's a different one.
A best level is somewhere
in the middle here.
Here's a best level here in
a very narrow response area.
So many of the neurons
in the auditory cortex
has to have these not
only characteristic
frequencies, but
also best levels.
If you, at their CF,
raise the sound level,
you get this type of pattern.
These are rate level functions.
So this is the firing rate, and
this is the tone level or tone
intensity.
And this is from a
number of neurons.
But just concentrate
on this one.
The firing rate goes up with
level, reaches a maximum,
and then it declines.
And at the highest level,
it doesn't respond anymore.
So we don't know
what this means.
It means somehow that
these neurons could
tell the animal or the person,
well, the sound level is x dB.
They can tell you
the sound frequency
is a certain number of
kilohertz in the sound level
if they're responding
maximally, is a certain SPO.
It's clearly very different.
Now, I brought that
up because people
have looked at that
in terms of coding
for preferred areas of space
where the neuron's response is
maximum.
And these are some data from
Clarey et al on azimuth level
response areas for
cortical neurons.
So what does that mean?
Well, they're recording from
a single neuron in the cortex.
And they have the
animal-- in this
it's, a cat-- in
an anechoic room.
And they move the sound
source around in azimuth.
We've talked about this with
experiments in the [INAUDIBLE].
And they study the
neuron's response
as a function of azimuth.
In this particular study, they
also varied the sound level.
And so that's what
the y-axis is here.
This is the sound level axis.
And what we just said is
that many neurons in cortex
have a preferred sound level.
They start to
increase their firing.
And that's what's meant
by this shading here,
the dark of the shading,
the higher the firing rate.
And then at high sound
levels, the firing trails off,
or it goes down to zero.
This is a level function
for these different neurons.
These are recordings now
from the auditory cortex
within a single column.
So shown here is the electrode
penetration going from unit
one down two unit 10.
And those are indicated here,
unit 1, down to unit 10.
And the cortical layers are
indicated by the Roman numerals
1 through 6 here.
And they're recording
these 10 different neurons
from a given cortical column.
And what's impressive
about these studies is
that the azimuth
of each of these
neurons, where it
prefers in space,
it is it a certain
azimuth, 45 to 90 degrees.
And that's as if
you were recording
from the left auditory cortex.
45 degrees would be
over here, to 90 degrees
would be straight over here.
So these neurons
are going to respond
when the speaker is in
a position over here.
And they're going to respond
when there's a moderate sound
level.
Not the lowest level, and
not the highest level.
So they prefer a
certain sound level.
And within a given column,
almost all of the neurons
have similar types of
azimuth level functions.
And remember, before
we said that these all
have about the same CF.
So a second thing that is common
to units in a given column
and auditory cortex is their
azimuth level response areas.
And that's shown
very nicely here.
These type of data suggests
that maybe these neurons
play some kind of
role in telling us
where a sound is coming from.
Like without this
column, maybe we really
wouldn't know that sound
sources were located
at 45 to 90 degrees over there
on the contralateral hemifield.
So there's been a lot of work
on auditory cortex and sound
localization.
And I want to get into it here.
So how do experimenters
test behaviorally
for how an animal
can localize sound?
Well, this is the
formal way to do it.
Here's an experimental animal.
It's going to a speaker
that emitted a sound.
Before, it had been sitting
in this central position
in the testing cage here.
Waiting maybe cued by
a light that's saying,
the trial's about to start.
And the animal then listens.
And this speaker up here
near b didn't emit the sound.
But the speaker down
here did emit the sound.
And then the animal is
trained to go to the speaker
that it had heard
emit the sound.
If it does that correctly,
there's a little food reward
area down below the speaker, and
the animal gets a food reward.
And the animals
are food deprived,
so they're motivated
to do this task.
In this case, the
speakers can be moved.
So you have removable speakers.
Or you can have an array of
speakers, as indicated here.
And the animal has to choose
which of the several speakers
emitted the sound, and
go to the correct one
to get the food reward.
And this has been
done with a variety
of experimental animals.
In this case, it
looks like a cat.
But they've also tested
rats and monkeys.
Now, there's a couple things
you have to worry about here.
You have to worry if your
sound is on a long time
that the animal isn't cheating.
And one way of cheating
would be for the animal
to sit still here, and
listen to the sound,
and then move a
little bit, maybe just
by bending over, saying, OK.
If I moved over here,
did the sound get louder?
Oh, that means the sound
is coming from this side.
So generally, these
tests are using
pretty short stimulae--
50, 100 milliseconds.
And during that
period, the animal
doesn't have a chance to move
and sample the sound field.
So what are the data in
normal hearing animals?
75% correct at distinguishing
which of the speakers
have emitted the
sound at 5 degrees.
So in that case, it's
when the movable speaker's
just 5 degrees.
With a, in this
case, 500 millisecond
long spectrally complex stimuli.
So animals are not as good at
this sound localization task.
In human performance, I think
back a few lectures ago,
we talked about the minimum
audible angle in humans
being a couple of degrees.
Maybe 1 degree.
In this case, the animal's
going to 5 degrees.
So it's not quite as good.
The animal can still do
the task surprisingly,
even if it has just
one functioning ear.
And how is that possible?
Well, the animal's pinna.
We talked about the
external ear or pinna,
providing you some
nice spectral queues.
And it looks like the spectrally
complex stimuli are being used.
So those spectra
cues are available.
But the minimum audible angle's
more like 10 to 12 degrees,
with just one ear with
a good pinna on it.
So the best performance
is with two ears.
Now, why am I going
over this paradigm?
Well, people have then
taken experimental animals
and studied them after lesions.
And we're talking about
the auditory cortex.
So let's look at the results of
lesioning the auditory cortex
on sound localization.
So looks like in
this study, they're
using the array of loudspeakers.
The lesion is located
in the auditory cortex.
And this is the right
side of the cortex.
This is the occipital or
back part of the cortex.
This is the front of the cortex.
So the lesion is made
on the right side.
When a lesion is made
on the right side
of the auditory
cortex, the animal
has problems localizing sound
in the opposite hemifield.
So the lesion is made
on the right side.
The animal doesn't know if it's
this speaker, this speaker,
this speaker, or
this speaker that's
emitting the sound as a random
performance on that side.
However, the animal
can distinguish
between the speakers in
the hemifield ipsilateral
to the lesion, which suggests
that the intact auditory
cortex is mediating
that behavior.
So there's a deficit
contralaterally
in the opposite hemifield.
And as you can see from this
lesion, which was located smack
in the middle of A1,
A1 lesions effectively
knock out sound
localization behavior.
So these early studies
suggested that A1
is critically important, and
is necessary for correct sound
localization behavior.
And in these early
studies, the lesions
were actually made surgically by
taking out some cortex tissue.
And they became, as time
went on in the mid1980s,
the lesion studies
became more elegant
in that before the lesion was
made, frequency mapping of A1
was made.
And this frequency
mapping is shown here.
This is best frequency, or CF.
Those terms are synonymous.
And this is distance
along the cortex.
And not the entire auditory
cortex, field A1, was removed,
but just a particular part,
just a little distance here.
And it was known
from the mapping
what CF was affected
by the lesion.
And the other CFs
were left intact.
You can test the animal for
any frequency you want to.
So you can test for
frequencies in the intact area,
or you can test for frequencies
in the lesioned area.
And it was shown very clearly
then by plotting performance.
This is a performance
axis, where
downward is very accurate.
This must be the number
of mistakes made.
So 0 is no mistakes made.
At the low frequencies
where the cortex is intact.
At the midfrequencies, where
the cortex is lesioned,
performance goes to chance.
And then at the
high frequencies,
again, where the
cortex is intact,
the performance gets
very few errors.
It's very good.
So this elegant
experiment shows then
that sound localization
proceeds by frequency
independent channels.
That is, the part of A1 that's
responsive to low frequencies
is mediating low sound
frequency localization.
And the part that's
responsive to high frequencies
is mediating high frequency
sound localization.
So a very beautiful
demonstration.
Now, these lesions were
done with the techniques
available at the time.
And it's very simple to go in
and destroy a part of cortex.
And for one reason
or another, people
decided to revisit these
lesion experiments,
even though they
were very convincing,
done in many, many
different species.
They decided to revisit them
with a completely different way
of making a lesion.
And this is the method of
inactivation by cooling.
And maybe many of you
have heard of this.
This might be the auditory
cortex, the surface.
This is layer 1 and the
different cortical layers.
The way you can
inactivate the cortex
by cooling is by taking a piece
of tubing that has cooling
fluid, or if you will, coolant.
And you can put this coolant
with a pump through this tube,
and you can lay the tube right
on the surface of the cortex.
And obviously, as the
coolant comes through here,
it's going to cool down
first the top layer
of the cortex, and
then the lower layers.
And finally, all of the cortex.
And you can assure yourself that
this cooling has inactivated
the cortex by doing things like
recording evoked potentials.
And what's elegant about
the cooling experiments
is that you can reverse them.
So I don't know
if this is a word,
but instead of coolant,
you can use a warmant,
and restore this to
body temperature.
And responses come back.
And what's very impressive is
that these kinds of experiments
can be done in animals
that are actually doing
a behavioral task,
localizing sound.
And clearly, those experiments
confirm these earlier lesion
experiments that
if you cool A1, you
get a deficit for a
localization ability
in the contralateral hemifield.
However, they have also come
up with an interesting result
in that if you cool
some other fields,
you also change sound
localization behavior.
Field PAF, when cooled, also
interrupts sound localization
behavior.
So that's posterior to A1.
And a small field
that's not named, but is
right on top of the anterior
ectosylvian sulcus, the AES.
When that area is cooled,
sound localization behavior's
also disrupted.
So I used to be
able to say, anyone
who performs this critical
function, sound localization,
well, not so sure
about it anymore.
Because if you cool
these other fields,
you have a disruption of
sound localization behavior.
If you cool any of the other
fields like A2, of VPAF,
or most of the
AAF, you don't get
an interruption of the behavior.
So what do we take
home from that?
Well, it seems like there
are several fields that
are important in sound
localization behavior.
Looks like A1, p, or PAF
as it's sometimes called,
and region near the
anterior ectosylvian sulcus
are all important.
And it's a little
bit controversial,
why the old lesions
didn't actually show this.
It seemed like in
the old lesions,
there were some studies which
said, if you leave A1 intact,
and you lesion all the
other cortical fields,
the animal can
still do the task.
That doesn't really fit with
the cooling results, which
has several fields
that are important.
So don't let me leave
you with the idea
that what these fields do
is only sound localization
behavior.
So A1 may be involved
then hundreds
of other tasks related
to our sense of hearing.
It's also involved in
sound localization.
So that's the right
way to think about it,
that these fields
probably do many things.
And I think if you got the gist
of what Doctor Schiller talked
about in vision, he's not a
big fan of this little area
of cortex does this
little function.
And over here, this little
area does this function.
He's more of a believer in
holistic cortex function
where to do a task, you
employ a lot of cortex;
auditory cortex if you're
doing an auditory task.
And perhaps the more
difficult a task is,
the motor cortex you use.
We'll see an evidence of that.
And next time, when we talk
about language processing
in humans from imaging studies.
So what else does cortex do
besides sound localization?
Oh, I forgot to talk
about auditory cortex
in humans, how many
tonotopic fields there are.
So I brought this nice
model of the primate brain.
And where is auditory
cortex in humans?
So this is a slice
of the brain, as
if you were to cut it like this.
And look at one slice.
And this is the right
and left temporal lobes.
So in the primate, you have
actually a separate lobe
of the brain called
the temporal lobe.
And in the temporal lobe,
you have to-- the primate
is a little bit more
difficult to examine
than the cat-- you have to pull
down the sylvian fissure, which
is between-- separates
the temporal lobe
from the parietal
cortex up here,
and look on the superior
surface of the temporal lobe,
and find the sight of A1.
And on that superior
temporal lobe surface,
you have a little gyrus that was
examined by an animus Heschl.
And Heschl's gyrus in
humans is the site of A1.
Some humans actually
have 2 Heschl's, gyri,
and they have their
A1 either on one
or both of the Heschl's gyri.
Now, looking at it from the
side view, in the temporal lobe,
you have the 3 big gyri.
Superior temporal gyrus,
inferior temporal gyrus--
sorry, middle temporal gyrus,
and inferior temporal gyrus.
And so A1 is on the
superior surface
of the superior temporal
gyrus on a little bitty gyrus
called Heschls.
So I'm going to pass
this model around.
And A1 is indicated by a little
piece of yellow tape there.
You can take a look at it.
And so that area,
Heschl's gyrus,
lights up very nicely
in imaging studies
when you present
auditory stimuli.
And so here's an imaging study
where the imaging plane was
parallel to the sylvian
fissure or sylvian sulcus,
and it's capturing just this
superior temporal gyrus.
And the plane is
looking down here.
And on Heschl's gyrus, you
see the left and the right
in this case, and just the
right in this case lighting up.
And you can use, of course,
different frequency sounds.
And change the
frequencies of those
sounds in a progression
from high frequencies
to low frequencies.
And you can draw
the progressions
that you see in imaging
signals, and that's
what's drawn with these arrows.
This is a MIT thesis
by Tom Talavage.
And he showed that
there were at least 1,
2, 3, 4, 5 clear progressions
of frequency sensitivity,
as if you were progressing
along tonotopically
mapped auditory cortical
fields in the human.
So remember, we saw 4
tonotopically mapped fields
in the cat.
And here we have at least
4, perhaps 5 in humans.
This one is labeled HG,
that's Heschl's gyrus.
And that's probably
primary auditory cortex.
This is a view looking down
on the superior surface
of the temporal lobe.
And this is what's
called an inflated view.
So it's like taking
that cortex model
and blowing it up
like a balloon.
And so the gyri are indicated
by the lighter shading,
and the sulci are indicated
by the more dark shading.
So that's what that is.
These are the dimensions here.
Posterior lateral
is that direction.
So we have multiple
tonotopically organized areas
in human auditory cortex.
Now, the paper that we read for
today's class by Penagos et al
talks about a center near A1,
near Heschl's gyrus, which
lights up in imaging studies
when the subject is presented
with sounds that have a
strong cessation of pitch.
So we talked about pitch
a little bit earlier
in the class.
And this is the
slide that I showed.
And it has a
different title now.
I think it was titled something
like complicated sounds,
or something like that.
Well, a complex sound
is simply a sound
that has multiple frequencies.
And so the stimulate
used in the paper
are complex sounds in that
they have multiple frequencies.
Earlier, we talk
about this in terms
of the context of
musical sounds.
Musical sounds almost always
have a fundamental frequency,
and then a whole
bunch of harmonics.
And to have a strong
sensation of pitch,
these musical sounds have
a very tight relationship
of the fundamental
and the harmonics.
They can't be a
random relationship.
They actually have to be
multiples of the fundamental.
For example, this complex of
tones, 100 hertz, 200 hertz,
300 hertz, 400, and so on,
are multiples of one another.
But if you had the
fundamental be 100,
the next harmonic be 150,
the next harmonic be 190,
the next harmonic be
230, where they're not
multiples of one another,
that stimulus would not
have a strong pitch
associated with it.
These musical sounds are
interesting because they
have a strong pitch.
The pitch is almost
always related
to the lowest, or fundamental
frequency of them.
And the pitch is very invariant.
As long as you have this nice
pattern of harmonics that
are related to each
other by multiples,
the pitch of this, no, which
I think is a piano note,
and the pitch of this note,
which-- let's do these two.
This is a guitar sound, and
this is an alto saxophone sound
where the fundamental
is the same.
The harmonic amplitude
is completely different.
But we recognize them as
playing the same pitch.
You can play a lot
around with the amplitude
of these harmonics.
I drew them all the same.
But clearly, they
can be any jumble
of pattern, as long as they're
multiples of one another.
You hear this as having
the same pitch as that.
And pitch is very
invariant to things
like where the sound
is coming from.
Pitch is invariant to how
high and level the sound is.
So pitch is a very fundamental
attribute of the sound.
Defined in the
psychophysics textbook
is, pitch is that attribute
of auditory sensation in terms
of which sounds may be
ordered on a musical scale.
So this one's low, this one's
middle, and this one's high.
And so when cochlear implant
users are programmed first,
they take this electrode,
and they stimulate it.
And the user says, yeah,
that sounds like a low one.
Then they activate
the next electrode.
And the audiologist
says, is this one higher,
or is this one lower?
And if it's higher, then they
route their speech processor,
higher frequencies,
into that electrode.
So they do a pitch ranking
in an auditory implants.
Now, pitch of the
complicated sound
depends strongly on the
fundamental frequency.
Everybody knows that.
Wow, you can play little
tricks in these stimuli.
You can do something like remove
the fundamental frequency.
How does that change the pitch?
Well, this guy becomes
the new fundamental.
That's what you might think.
But actually, removing
this fundamental
is just like playing around
with the amplitude of the higher
frequencies.
It doesn't change
the pitch at all.
And this is called the
missing fundamental.
And that's actually lucky
for cheap speakers that
might not have a very good base.
The fundamental is
hardly there at all,
but the piece still
sounds musical,
and it's not changed a lot.
Or why does that happen?
Well, this very nice multiples
of 100 is still present.
And so the temporal pattern
of all these harmonics, if you
add them up and look at this
thing in the time domain--
remember, this was
a graph frequency.
Whatever this looks
like, it's going
to repeat after 10 milliseconds.
Because it's period
is still 100 hertz.
I'm not a very good artist,
but it's going to be the same.
And it's going to
be the same here.
So each 10 milliseconds, it's
going to repeat its pattern.
It has the same regularity, even
if you remove the fundamental.
Now, you may not believe me.
So let me give you
a demonstration.
And in this
demonstration, there's
a whole bunch of harmonics
presented at first.
And then in the
second presentation,
they remove the fundamental.
And you should listen
to see if the pitch
that your ears hear
changes at all.
On the second presentation,
they remove this next harmonic,
and so on, and so forth.
And I think they
end up with removing
four different
harmonics after they
present the complete stimulus.
So listen to this demonstration
of the missing fundamental.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
-Pitch of the missing
fundamental, or virtual pitch.
You will hear a complex tone
with 10 harmonics, first
complete, and then with the
lower harmonics successively
removed.
Does the pitch of
the complex change?
The demonstration
is repeated once.
[SERIES OF PITCHES]
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: I think
it's pretty clear.
Does everybody want
to discuss this?
So when you lose
these first 1 or 2,
the pitch doesn't
change a great deal.
But by the end of
the demo, this pitch
is starting to
sound a lot higher.
So if you move some of
these around or decrease
their amplitude, this
one's a low fundamental.
The pitch doesn't
change a great deal.
Now, that is what
they did in the paper
that we read for today.
What they do is they
have a complex tone
with a whole bunch of harmonics.
And they do a clever
thing like they've
done on this demonstration.
They just select
some of the harmonics
to present to the observers
in the imaging study.
And the cleverness
of this study is
that by clever filtering
of this harmonic pattern,
they can give you
some stimulae that
have really strong
sensations of pitch.
Or in this one
case, which I think
is condition 2, a very weak
sensation of pitch because
of the particular
harmonics they've chosen.
So they have 3 stimulate.
They giving you a strong
sensation of pitch,
and one that has a very weak
sensation of pitch because
of the clever way
they've filtered it.
And further clevering,
all of these stimulae
have the same regularity.
They have the same
regularity in terms
of their temporal waveform.
So the cleverness
of this study then
is that the temporal
waveform hasn't
changed in terms
of its regularity.
But the subject's
impression of the pitch,
whether it's a strong pitch
or a weak pitch, has changed.
So by weak pitch,
I mean something
that sounds like a
noise, or a click.
Those stimulate don't have
strong sensation of pitch
because they're random.
They don't have this nice
pattern of harmonics.
So I wasn't convinced by
this verbiage and the figure.
So I decided I wanted to
listen to these stimuli myself.
And it was convenient, because
I know all three authors.
So Hector Penagos, when
he wrote this paper,
was a graduate student
in the speech and hearing
bioscience and
technology program.
Jennifer Melcher
is a faculty member
over at the Eaton-Peabody Lab.
Her office is
right next to mine.
And Andrew Oxenham was a
faculty member here at MIT,
and has since moved to
University of Minnesota.
So I started asking the
authors, because they're
all friends of mine, if
I could have the demos.
And one of them said, well,
it's been a long time.
I'm not sure I still have them.
And the other author,
is the second author
I went to-- I won't
say who it is,
said, I got them right away.
So he sent them-- that author
sent them to me right away.
And so I have them, and
I'll play them for you.
Now, you'll listen
to these stimuli.
And what was
surprising to me that I
didn't get from the
methods of the paper
is that they don't just keep
presenting the same thing over
and over.
The pitch actually moves around.
And that's one of the
nice parts of this demo
is that you can actually tell
that the pitch is moving around
in the ones with strong
sensation of pitch.
Second thing that
they did was, they
added a little bit of
background noise to these.
And it turns out
that when you present
a whole bunch of harmonics
with the speaker,
the speaker will introduce
a little distortion.
Your ear introduces distortion.
And they wanted to mask
that distortion out.
And the distortion is
pretty low in level.
And so this noise that's
a continuous background
is a pretty effective mask.
I think you can still hear that
these stimuli, in some cases,
have pretty strong
sensations of pitch.
So I'm going to start out
with condition one, which they
say has a strong
sensation of pitch.
And you can judge for
yourself, whether you
hear the pitch moving around.
[PITCH WITH STATIC]
PROFESSOR: Maybe it
will go on forever.
I don't know how long
it would go on for.
Well, anyway, could you
hear those moving around?
You could rank them.
Here's number 2.
[PITCH WITH STATIC]
PROFESSOR: It's
moving around, right?
Number 3.
[LOWER PITCH WITH STATIC]
PROFESSOR: OK.
Now, to me, those have strong
sensations of pitch, I believe.
I'm a believer.
Now, here's the
last one that they
say has a weak [INAUDIBLE].
[PITCH WITH STATIC]
PROFESSOR: OK.
So at first, I was expecting to
hear no change in pitch at all.
But actually, the pitches
change a little bit.
And so when you go back and say,
it's a weak sensation of pitch,
OK.
Right?
So we're believers?
Or does anybody want
to say-- all right.
What happened in
their imaging study?
Well, this is
pretty small figure.
But it summarizes the
results in that they
had an activation of
the circled area, which
is near Heschl's gyrus-- just,
I believe, anterior to it.
And this is the place that
had a high activation.
In the cases of the
stimuli, was strong.
Psychophysical
sensations of pitch,
but had a low
activation in the case
where there was a weak
sensation of pitch.
Other areas of the
brain-- for example,
Heschl's gyrus lit up for
all of the conditions.
And what's interesting
about this study
is they examined some of
the subcortical nuclei
that we've been talking about.
For example, the inferior
colliculus and the cochlear
nuclei.
And these are the activations
for those centers.
Cochlear nucleus activates
pretty much the same
for all of the conditions.
This black one is the
one that was associated
with the weak
sensation of pitch.
The inferior colliculus,
perhaps a little bit less
activation for that stimulus,
but not significantly so.
In the case of this center
for pitched salience
in the auditory cortex, clearly
there's a lot less activation.
For that stimulus with the
weak sensation of pitch,
about the same amount
of activation as you'd
find with noise bursts there.
So that, I think,
clearly demonstrates,
and other imaging
studies have clearly
demonstrated that this area
is the region of cortex that
becomes very active when
we experience stimuli
with strong sensations of pitch.
In experimental animals,
recordings from, for example,
the marmoset auditory cortex.
You find neurons in
an equivalent area
that respond very nicely
to harmonic complexes that
have strong
sensation of pitches.
If you remove too
many of the harmonics
where the pitch changes a
lot, the neurons fire less.
And clearly, in those
cases, remember,
most neurons in the
cortex are finally
tuned to sound frequency.
You can remove a whole bunch
of these lower harmonics,
and not change the response,
suggesting that there is really
signaling, that there is pitch
associated with that stimulus
rather than there's a
certain kind of frequency.
So that's the bottom
line for this study.
Let me just mention
a couple things that
make auditory
experiments difficult
when you're trying
to image the brain.
Has anybody listened
to an fMRI machine?
An imager?
Very loud, right?
So you have problems
with the subjects
listening to the stimulus that
you intend to present to them
rather than listening to
the imaging noise itself.
And so in this study,
they went to great extent
to try to reduce
the imaging noise.
The subjects were wearing
protective earmuffs,
and the stimulae
were loudspeakers
that led to those
earmuffs in long tubes.
Of course, you can't have a
speaker right near the ear
because there's a magnet
associated with the speaker.
So you have to have the
speaker outside the imager.
So they actually turned one
of the imaging pumps off.
There is a lot of challenge in
imaging such small structures
as the cochlear nuclei
in inferior colliculus.
And they said to improve
the detection of activation
in these brainstem
[? structures, ?]
the data were activated
using cardiac triggering.
So does anybody know
what that means?
Well, when your heart beats,
it pulses on all the arteries,
and actually moves
the brainstem.
Brainstem is so small,
it can be moved.
Cortex is moving too, but the
areas are generally bigger.
And so if you weren't going
to take care of the heartbeat,
the brainstem might
be imaged when
it was in this
position at one point.
And the next image might,
when it was over here.
So what cardiac
triggering is, they
record the EKG from the subject.
And when they see the
QRS complex, or whatever
waveform from the
EKG, and they say,
that's the time
to take the image.
So they only take the
image at a certain point
relative to the cardiac cycle.
So the brain, even
though it's moving,
it's always moved in
this certain position.
So that's a challenge
that's associated
with imaging small structures
like these brainstem nuclei.
So then, another
property, at least
of this field of
the auditory cortex,
is to process stimulae that
to have high pitch salience.
So we've had two functions
associated with auditory cortex
then, just as a summary here.
One is processing stimuli
with high pitch salience,
and the other is
processing sound stimuli
that change in location.
So those are the two things you
can really hang your hat on,
and what is done at the auditory
cortex in terms of function.
And for the pitch
sensitive area,
you have this area near A1.
For the localization, you
have A1, posterior field,
and a field near the
anterior ectosylvian sulcus,
as we know currently.
All right.
Questions?
If not, have a
good Thanksgiving.
Don't eat too much, or enjoy
eating too much, I guess.
I'll see you on Monday.